hong kong poumon financier de l'asie un
territoire de plus de 7 millions
d'habitants où tous les plus grands
espoirs côtoient les pires déceptions
veulent encore nous sommes sur l'île de
lantau un décor paradisiaque mais pour
vanessa une demandeuse d'asile
c'est devenu une prison violet kidnappés
dans ses philippiques natale et la fuit
à hong kong en 2002 mais bien vite la
désillusion s'est installé dans ce
territoire où les réfugiés n'ont aucun
droit ni assistance cantonnés dans des
logements insalubres
elle va donner naissance à qui an'a en
on
le nord du mali
et puis en mai 2013 son destin va
basculer davantage avec l'arrivée dans
cet hôtel d'edward snowdon c'est l'homme
le plus recherché par les états unis
parce qu'il a dévoilée entre autres un
programme gouvernemental de surveillance
de masse vanessa et d'autres réfugiés
vont l'aider en le cachant dans leur
logement
quand même rencontre avec des victimes
d'agressions et de torture au sri lanka
arbitres est un déserteur de l'armée
arrivé à hong kong en 2003 celui qu'on
appelle le garde du corps de snowdon n'a
aucun regret même si le danger d'être
expulsé dans son pays d'origine est
alors monté d'un cran on comprend à
cause de son coup de main à snowdon
vanessa est devenu une proie facile pour
les autorités de hong kong qui veulent
plus que jamais l'expulser
et c'est là que les avocats montréalais
vont arriver à la rescousse de ces
réfugiés à la base leur avocat me et un
avocat d'origine montréalaise d'origine
canadienne robert thibault qui les
aurait présenté en qu'une qui
représentait snowdon aussi et qui a mis
de l'avant la possibilité avec nous
d'étudier une possibilité de
réinstallation au canada ses avocats
canadiens ont donc créé une organisation
sans but lucratif pour parrainer de
façon privée donc son fonds publics
ce qu'ils ont appelé les orges de
snowdon soit vanessa arbitres et cinq
autres réfugiés dont trois enfants en
bas âge on est à hong kong où le
gouvernement local refuse de laisser le
hcr le haut commissariat pour les
réfugiés de l'onu
agir sur le terrain ce qui veut dire que
les demandeurs d'asile ici ne peuvent
pas avoir accès donc au programme des
nations unies pour être qualifié comme
réfugiés seule solution utiliser la loi
canadienne pour que le canada puisse se
substituer au hcr afin de pouvoir
qualifier ces réfugiés
résultat après deux ans de travail
acharné les avocats de vanessa lui
apprenne le 21 février qu'elle et sa
fille qui en a aujourd'hui âgé de 7 ans
sont acceptés par le canada comme
résidents permanente entre les chats les
projets pour cette deuxième chance se
bousculent dans la tête de vanessa
[Musique]
c'est donc à montréal que qui anna va
vivre et elle sait déjà ce qu'elle va
faire quand elle sera grande
[Musique]
une fin heureuse pour elle et sa maman
mais ce n'est pas le cas pour les autres
demandeurs d'asile le canada à un prix
d'émission quand même
expéditive dans leur dossier reste que
les deux autres dossiers sont toujours
un traitement reste qu'il faut accélérer
les procédures pour les deux autres
dossiers parce que les procédures de
renvois sont imminentes puis un risque
de renvoi le bien réel parmi ces anges
de snowdon en danger d'expulsion
il y a le sri lankais sous peine avec sa
femme et ses deux jeunes enfants le jour
nous devons le rencontrer on cogne on se
fait accueillir par une ambulance sous
poon est hospitalisé devant nos yeux il
est en détresse psychologique
on est dans des dents les éléments de
détresse possiblement les plus forts de
nous les plus graves d'une vie de
quelqu'un vous n'avez pas le droit
d'être vous vous êtes vous appelle vous
n'avez pas le droit de travailler vous
avez le droit de donner votre vie vous
n'avez pas le droit de rien faire en
fait puis les enfants
vous n'avez pas de passeport impôts
nationalité puis vous risquer tout
moment d'être envoyées vers votre pays
d'origine à argy tu lui bien que secoué
par le départ de son amie vanessa est
encore à la merci des autorités de hong
kong y voit malgré tout un peu d'espoir
à monex
mais b mais comme toutes les petites
filles de son âge les princesses les
licornes et les toutous feront partie de
ce long voyage vers le pays de toutes
les promesses d'ailleurs pour elles
foulé pour la première fois le sol
canadien aura une signification toute
particulière
effectivement c'est un enfant qui est
steckley smic et apatrides qui leur vaut
se retrouvent avoir le droit pour la
première fois de sa vie d'exister et de
vivre le ouellet ce qui est assez
incroyable confiance à une jeune enfant
de 7 ans qui en fait pas vraiment droit
d'être allé puisqu'elle est peu reconnu
pied est le pote de l'existence ou de
citoyenneté ou nationalité c'est assez
troublant